[Music]
so first more show of hands how many of
you have heard about cloud identity I
know you're all here how many of you
think that gee sweetest loud identity
[Music]
okay good
how many of you have heard of the term B
encore okay great and how many of you
think that device management is a part
of cloud identity okay great
okay I think I hope you'll find the
session today interesting so let's see
so we'll cover the following topics this
afternoon
we'd start with an overview of cloud
identity we'll go over the various
features talk about the roadmap go over
some exciting demos Colin will talk
about their cloud identity experience
and journey at essence and we'll tie all
this together and at the end we will
have some time for Q&A so it's pretty
amazing to see how the generation of
today has got vastly different
expectations from what I had growing up
so the technology has come a really long
way in the last 20 years there was a
time when my computer at work was a lot
better than what I had at home and my
internet connectivity at work was way
better than what I had at home and in
fact I would come to work and I could
only access data within my office
boundaries because I knew no better
today's generation on the contrary
expects way more flexibility they want
to be able to access data from anywhere
from any device and the workspace as we
know it is going through a massive
digital transformation just to support
their needs and you as IT
decision-makers are at the forefront
making all this happen
an Identity and Access Management is
front and center of this revolution so
we're living in a parameter list or an
edge world a world in which the
enterprise security parameter is no
longer your office front door but
instead it is elastic and it's dispersed
and it's wrapped around each user and
each device
and everything is based on context and
your users are not just your employees
but now they are your vendors they're
your contractors they're your customers
and all of these different people have
different different needs and they need
to access different information
different applications from different
places and from different devices so
clearly a different approach to identity
and access management is critical and
important existing approaches of very
complex very time-consuming and very
cumbersome they were built for the
on-premise world and they are not
optimized for today's cloud forward
world so with more users requesting
access for more information and for more
devices than ever before IT teams
struggle with a complex network of
managing applications devices users and
shadow IT is also a huge problem in this
space but there in also lies our
opportunity so in 2011 Google came up
with a new model of defining access
management which is what we call as
beyond core it's a new enterprise
security model which started as an
internal Google initiative to enable
every employee to be able to work from
untrusted networks without the use of a
traditional VPN beyond court if eclipsed
the access controls from that of the
network parameter to that of the
application it's all around each user
and each device and thereby allowing
employees to work securely from any
location so cloud identity helps bring
the beyond car provision to your
organization it is designed around the
core pillars of being simple smart and
secure so people devices applications
directory and extensible api's are all
first-class citizens managed within a
unified single pane of glass people
devices and context is your new security
parameter so policies are defined and
they're enforced to control access based
on the user's identity and the context
of that request
so while cloud identity helps you as an
organization to move towards the cloud
we also want to make sure we meet the
organization where they are in their
cloud journey by supporting your
on-premise Identity and Access
Management systems so in the next
section we'll talk about some of the key
features of cloud identity
we'll also go over the road map but I
want you to remember that cloud identity
enjoys the following key differentiators
first and foremost cloud identity enjoys
Google great security you can control
access to SAS applications and for
strong multi-factor authentication
protect your users and accounts get
automatic protections against hijacking
with with machine learning data from
Google services and above all we ensure
that everything is simple it's simple
not just for the IT administrator but
also for the end-user and it's about
meeting you where you are in your
journey and we believe in supporting
your hybrid identity story so let's
first talk about the people with cloud
identity enterprise's can automatically
provision accounts into Google's cloud
directory using api's or using our tool
called the Google cloud directory sync
accounts can also be automatically
provisioned into third party systems
using a feature called auto provisioning
and that ensures both end-user as well
as administrator convenience and also
has security compliance Google protects
all cloud identity accounts against
account takeover compromised or
hijacking through the use of machine
learning data from overrate services
with over 1 billion plus 30 day active
users so cloud identity offers multiple
options to protect user accounts with
strong authentication methods which we
call 2-step verification that includes
push notifications one-time passwords
password alerts and so on and further as
awareness of potential vulnerabilities
right associated with telephony options
like to where like SMS or Royce codes
has increased we also provide admins
with the ability we give them the choice
to disable these telephony options like
SMS or voice codes if they so choose or
desire as a2s we method for your users
we've also long advocated the use of
security keys as the strongest and the
most phishing resistant authentication
method for high-value users customers
have long told us that it can be hard to
source and roll out security keys so we
have the tightened security key which is
a Phaedo based security ski where
includes firmware that has
developed by Google to verify its
integrity it's available through the
Google store but it's rolling out in
other regions very soon
so we'd also like to announce that we
can you can use your Android phone now
as a security key this is a feature
that's available in beta and this offers
both strongest protection and
authentication for your users while
offers convenience for the users because
now it's a one-time enrollment process
there is no additional hardware or apps
required and you get that strong
authentication and protection for your
high value users cloud identity also
comes with the security center that
provides controls from prevention to
detection to remediation right so admins
can manage and improve your security
posture within the organization for
example they can get proactive phishing
protection they can get actionable
security insights through the dashboard
for example phishing risks and they can
diagnose triage and resolve security
incidents through the investigation tool
we're excited to announce the cloud
identity will now allow integration with
third-party HRI systems such as bamboo
HR ADP Ultimate Pro and and and namely
to enable automated user lifecycle
management and this will be generally
available in the summer and shivani will
now give a quick peek at what this will
look like hello everyone so here's a
quick peek at what this integration is
going to look like let's say your
company uses bamboo HR for storing
employee information and now your IT
admin wants to sync this employee
information from bamboo HR to cloud
identity the way they can do that is by
accessing the extra the external
directory section of the admin console
here you can add your bamboo HR external
directory when you click on add you get
to this page where you can add some
brief information about bamboo HR as you
can see we need to also add a service
account now this service account is
going to be used to sync the employee
information from bamboo HR to cloud
identity when you click on add directory
a skin endpoint URL is generated and now
you need to copy this endpoint
and paste it into bamboo HR setup page
now that syncs the employee information
from bamboo HR to Clair identity
once the sink is set up any time you add
modify or delete a user in bamboo HR
this information gets automatically
updated in cloud identity and your
company no longer needs to maintain any
manual sync between these two systems ok
great so now let's talk about
applications so we first spoke about
people then let's talk about
applications cloud IDE comes with a very
rich catalog of thousands of federated
apps that support sam'l as well as IEC
standards in addition we're happy to
announce that cloud identity will also
support password based single sign-on
into those applications that do not
support the federated standards this
will be available generally available
end of the summer and this was a key
feature that was a part of our bid iam
acquisition also coming soon is a new
end-user hub where users can quickly
access all of your apps from one single
place a key tenet of cloud identity is
the ability to meet organizations where
they are in their cloud journey while
the adoption of SAS apps continues to
grow many businesses still rely on
traditional legacy on-premise LDAP based
applications so secure LDAP in cloud
identity allows you to use a single
access management platform to access
both your SAS as well as your on-premise
LDAP applications so what this means is
that admins can manage both the SAS as
well as your on-premise LDAP
applications from one single control
plane and end-users can use the same
cloud identity credentials and can log
into both the SAS as well as on Prem
applications so with several partners
that are integrating with secure LDAP
today and we're happy to announce our
latest entry into the club get lab so
now let's see this in action thank you
video so let's see a demo of secure LDAP
now let's say your company uses gate lab
to write and manage code and now your
admin wants to configure secure LDAP
with git lab so your engineering team
can log in to gate lab using their cloud
identity credentials
the way this is gonna work is the admin
has to first go to the LDAP section of
the admin console as you can see on the
screen now you can add a new LDAP client
by clicking on add client let's give our
LDAP client a name let's call it gitlab
we can add a description if you want to
but for now I'm going to skip it let's
click on continue now this takes me to
the access permissions page where I can
configure access permissions for my
gitlab LDAP client I can figure out how
much of my directory information this
client should be able to access for
example I can click on entire domain if
all my employees should be able to login
into gate lab or I can select a specific
or you now if I click on edit I can see
that I can select the engineering or you
because only my engineers need to write
code in get lab let's hit save when I
scroll down I can also select what user
and group information the client should
be able to get access to let's click on
add and click on engineering because the
client should only be able to access
engineering let's allow the client to
read group information and now click on
add LDAP client now this should generate
a certificate you need to now download
this certificate and then upload the
certificate to your LDAP client you can
do so for gate lab by following this
public document that gate lab has
published by by reading the instructions
in the configuring gate lab section you
can now upload your certificate and set
that sync between gate lab and Claire
identity once this is done what it means
for your employees is they can now is
your engineering team can now use their
cloud identity credentials to log in to
get lab and your admin can now use the
same admin console the same single pane
of glass to to both manage your SAS
applications and your on-prem
applications
Thank You Bonnie
now let's talk about devices so we spoke
about people we spoke about applications
and now let's talk about devices so
cloud identity helps organizations to
enforce policies consistently across
multiple endpoints whether it's iOS
Android or Chrome we're happy to
announce that we now have more than 55
million 30-day devices under management
so admins can enforce screen locks or
pass codes to secure devices they can
buy corporate data on devices view and
search for devices export details all of
this can be done with basic device
management functionality without the
need of an installed agent which is a
very powerful functionality to secure
your devices while keeping your users
productive admins can instant can
whitelist apps they can separate your
work and personal data distribute apps
and lastly admins can audit devices set
up rules to manage these devices at
scale so we spoke about beyond Corp at
the start of the session beyond Corp
allows a new way of working in a
parameter list or an edge world where
everything is based on context it's
based on the user's identity and the
context of that originating request so
the components in the beyond Corp model
are user trust you have device trust you
have the contacts right so you have a
rules engine which actually then
processes access to these resources
based on the context what is the IP
address what is the location what is the
time session so on and all of these
components are actually powered by
different assets in the Google cow in
the Google Cloud stack and the assets
include cloud identity there is
something called endpoint verification
the Google front-end access context
manager and then you have the different
enforcement points like whether it's
Google IEP there is I am cloud identity
VPC service controls and so on we're
happy to announce that context-aware
access is generally available for cloud
IEP and it's now in open beta 4G suite
so please go try it out and see this in
action
Thank You Vidya now I'm going to demo
context of our axis so let's say your
company has a lot of confidential files
stored in Google Drive and now your IT
admin wants to make sure that employees
can only access Google Drive from court
network so only when you're in your in
your workplace and your IT admin doesn't
care about Gmail they always want you to
check Gmail so you're up to date with
your emails and so they don't mind if
you can check your email outside of work
so let's see this in action how does
your IT admin set up such a security
policy your IT admin can set up the
security policy from the context-aware
access page of the admin console now
i've already set this policy up for you
so i'm going to show you how this was
set up if i click on the access level I
can see a policy called Corp IP address
now if I click on assign access levels I
can see to whom this access level was
assigned so when I click on this section
I can see that it was assigned to me now
I'm present in the legal organization
unit so when I click on the legal
organization unit I can scroll down and
see that the Corp IP address access
level was assigned to drive in Docs now
this means that I won't be able to
access drive and dogs outside of work
however you can also see that it's not
assigned to Gmail so I should be able to
access Gmail outside of work so let's
see this in action well where am i I'm
in a hotel I'm clearly not in a Google
building so I should be able to access
Gmail but I shouldn't be able to access
Drive so if I try to access Gmail yay I
can access Gmail and if I try to access
drive I shouldn't be able to access
drive there you see I don't have access
now let me walk you through how you can
set up more such security policies you
can set up a security policy by going
here and then creating a new access
level and then assigning that access
level in the second in the second
section to a specific organization unit
your entire domain and to a particular
application so let's go ahead and create
a new access level let's say I'm the IT
admin of your organization and I don't
want you to access Google Drive from
outside your Corp device
so if you're using your personal laptop
I don't want you to be able to access
Google Drive from your personal laptop
the way I can do that is by creating a
new access level let's give it a name
corporate device only when I click on
continue I can now set up some
conditions when I click on attribute I
want to select device policy because the
policy is related to devices I can click
on yes for whether the device should
have a password to add more
enforcement's I can add other
restrictions too such as I can I can
enforce a minimum Mac OS version or a
minimum Crow's Chrome OS version now I
need to select required under corporate
owned device I can add other conditions
and they'll all get compounded but for
now I will keep it simple and I'll click
on create access level to create this
access level now I can see that in
addition to Corp IP address and the
other access levels that that are here I
have the corporate device only access
level created I can assign this newly
created access level to whichever
application that I want to assign it to
let's assign it to me again because
other people are probably demoing with
the same customer so I want to break
them and assign it to drive in Docs I
can compound multiple access levels so I
already have the Corp IP address access
level assigned to me I can also click on
corporate device only and hit save so
that's how you create new access levels
and assign these access levels to
whichever organization unit you want to
if you want to assign it to your entire
domain you can click on the entire
domain now I'm going to hand it off to
Colin from essence to talk about his
experiences using cloud identity there
we go
thank you I knew there'd be some glitch
and the other glitch you can see we've
got the status bar on the screen which
we can't work out where it's there I'm
from essence I'm Collin McCarthy I'm the
VP for global IT been with the company
for 10 years 9 years started in 2010
when it was a lot simpler time where we
just had one office and 60 users on one
app that we would log into with single
sign-on with you know sam'l based
application
but I'm gonna talk to you about our
growth our journey using G suite and how
we've been using identity cloud identity
and the context where access policy that
we've been testing for the last few
months and deployed in North America and
also recently in London so essence of
course has been a longtime user of
Google Apps we've started with Google
Apps for Business in 2009 and being very
much a cloud based company that has
allowed us to have a lot of growth where
in the last nine years we've grow to
sixty offices sorry
nineteen offices and 1800 users around
the world we've also deployed a lot of a
cloud identity security products that
have been released over the last few
years
MFA in 2013 and also mobile device
management in 2014 as show of hands how
many people have got MFA and mobile
device management on their Android and
iOS devices
I should see every hand go up if
somebody's hand doesn't hasn't gone up
I'm sure you're a little bit embarrassed
if you do if you are using gee Swede and
cloud identity you certainly should have
MFA and also mobile device management
management deployed across your
enterprise there are obviously a number
of challenges that we have we G sweet
Dee sweet is brilliant you can access it
in any location on any device and that's
one of the challenges from accessing it
from any location in any device over the
last few years I've discovered and seen
a lot more stringent security
requirements coming down from vendors
and clients where you know in 2011 2012
maybe if you had a new client they would
ask you 40 security questions last year
the security audits that we would get
from clients and vendors and other
suppliers would have 200 to 400
different security questions so
everybody has a very much a security
focused mindset and thankfully with
Clara identity and context where access
you now have the ability to have
confidence you're able to enforce those
corporate policies across any device
that's SS accessing
data one of the barriers for deploying
any new security feature is of course
making it seamless for the end-user
because the last thing you want to do is
deploy security but then in inhibit and
make working with the your corporate
technology more of a hindrance to your
end-users because if they don't like
that technology or if it requires too
much of a disruption on the way that
they work there are naturally going to
bypass that and they'll find other ways
of working which is obviously how shadow
IT has become such a big corporate
problem so with any deploying any new
security feature it's all about making
it seamless as possible for the end-user
and one of the good things with context
where access as it was shown if it's a
corporate owned machine you can update
to upload all the service or the serial
numbers and take ownership of those
machines and apply the policies so that
you know that your data is secure but it
doesn't really impact the end-user
whatsoever so the challenges that we
have solved with cloud identity you know
with the bamboo HR and the hrs
integration we're going to very much be
able to streamline our onboarding
process and also the off-boarding
process making sure that accounts are
created at the right time people have
the right access to the right resources
but also when a staff member leaves you
can make sure that our account is
automatically D provisioned with mobile
device management we've always been able
to put in security restrictions or
security policies on Android and iOS
devices now we can do those same
policies on Windows and Macs and also
with the improvement in the account
security we're able to disable
phone based SMS and phone call
verification and then go to the security
key type concept of managing the MFA for
our users so some of the scenarios that
we've been able to solve or could
potentially solve our essence with
context to our access and I'm sure this
will be the same for many organizations
here is if you do have temporary workers
in your organization you can specify
that they can only access applique
from corporate machines inside your
corporate office you could also make
sure that your full-time employees can
only access data from devices that that
comply with your security policy which
obviously is going to be an encrypted
hard disk and a password and as we shown
potentially a minimal level of OS it's
very likely that we will at some point
disallow the use of Windows 7 I only
have one user in New York at the moment
who's still using Windows 7 at home I've
given her notice that she needs to
upgrade and and move to Windows 10 it's
the same for any of their Mac OS
versions that that people might be
running with the with that belief on Mac
OS is secure I don't need to update my
OS from 2014 so you you do have the
ability to do those OS level
restrictions the other thing you can do
is you can also as the product develops
we're going to be able to do time-based
restrictions so you can make sure that
your employees dependent on their role
are only able to access applications
through business hours also they will
give you alerts or give you do
restrictions on accessing data from
high-risk locations so that you know
that if you're you know New York
employees I'm going to be traveling to
China then there's no reason why their
account should be logging in on China or
Slovakia or any other country around the
world also you can specify that
employees that are leaving your company
may be you as part of the off-boarding
process maybe you say that they can only
access their corporate network from
inside the corporate office it's you
know just a good security way that you
with this you can manage the onboarding
and the off-boarding process so how did
we deploy it this was for us and my and
my colleagues it was probably the the
smoothest largest deployment that we
have we have done to date over all of
our years you know everybody I'm
assuming has the ability to push out an
application to their their corporate and
devices whether you're using Jam for
Microsoft Intune so we pushed out the
the native helper that's required
I'm forcing the Chrome extension to be
installed to everybody's profile but
what we did before we did all of those I
guess that the technical side of it we
did spent a lot of time on the human
side of it and made sure that we had
executive buy-in from the CEO I was on
board with the changes that we were
going to make we alerted all of the
regional office leads that we were going
to be pushing this out to their to their
staff and then we also did a series of
emails or notices on our on our internal
system telling users what was going to
happen and we also educated our support
staff and told them you know these are
going to be this is the change that
we're going to be making these are the
the probably the issues that you're
going to come across you know and if you
put out a good documentation to your
end-users about a change you can
probably expect that 10 to 10 to 20
percent of those users aren't going to
read or action those documents so if you
have 500 users your helpdesk and expect
between you know to have between 50 and
100 users having a problems on on any
particular day and that's what my poor
colleagues in London had on Monday when
we enforced context-aware access you
know we were we spend a lot of time
working with our end users I did a small
trial I tested it on on my test account
got very familiar with the application
and the first and the the policies that
could be enforced they ended it to four
people did it to 20 people and then
pushed it out of 400 people and probably
in the space of about 10 days did all of
that and really honed the the
communication and created some animated
gifs so they could see the whole process
and that that was our process through
that thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you : okay so now um let's put
this all together in terms of defining
what a typical customer journey could
look like so Acme Corp is a company
which has many of its IT assets
on-premise many of their systems right
the devices there are print servers they
are VPN servers etc are integrated into
Active Directory for authentication or
for other identity needs Acme Corp CIO
has decided that they want to move to
the cloud so that they can embrace this
beyond Corp philosophy and they can make
their users and employees way more
productive and work securely so that
they can work from anywhere from any
device and also it helps increase acne
corpse return on investment so first to
integrate with with cloud apps Acme Corp
decides to replace their on-premise SSO
solution with cloud identity so they use
the tool called the Google cloud
directory sync and that tool essentially
syncs information users groups and other
metadata information from Active
Directory into Google's cloud directory
they also replace their productivity
suite with G suite now that they have
successfully integrated all your cloud
apps with cloud identity they start
integrating their legacy on premise as
LDAP based applications using cloud
identities secure LDAP functionality
that we visited earlier they can also
then integrate they are VPN servers as
part of their IT infrastructure Matt :
active on Linux devices with secure LDAP
and potentially also manage all their
other windows type of devices with cloud
identity in the future so now you've
heard quite a bit this afternoon and you
can see there's a ton of great
functionality that is in the product and
the good news is all of this
functionality is available for one
single license and many of you in this
room might be existing G suite customers
or you might be using Google cloud
platform and you might wonder how does
licensing work in such a situation so
the good news is cloud identities free
functionality is available or is built
into G suite basic and business SKUs
if you are a GG sweeeeet enterprise user
the cloud identity stand-alone product
which we call as cloud identity premium
is built into that product so as a
customer if you want to use
functionality like context-aware access
with Shivani demo demoed earlier you
have the option of buying or upgrading
to G suite enterprise or you could buy
the standalone cloud identity product
and use that alongside your existing G
suite basic and business subscriptions
if you are using Google cloud platform
today you can sign up for the free cloud
identity account as part of your regular
cloud onboarding experience however if
you require premium identity
functionality for example if you want
session management controls so that you
can actually control session lengths for
your different accessing your cloud
admin console you would then need the
cloud identity premium product which you
can then add on as an upgrade so in a
nutshell cloud identity is a unified
platform to manage your people devices
and applications it enables the beyond
Corp vision and allows your users to be
truly productive but extremely secure
with features like context-aware access
it increases productivity with single
sign-on to thousands of applications
both by supporting federated standards
like sam'l and open IDC as well as
password base SSO for those applications
that don't support the federated
standards it provides account security
with MFA as well as security keys
security keys from outside or the Titans
security key from Google and it very
much enables hybrid identity and meets
organizations where they are in your
current cloud journey so this is either
with the help of tools like secure LDAP
or directory sync tools like the Google
cloud directory sync which syncs
information from your on-premise systems
to Google's cloud directory and again
all of this is available for a single
subscription and you can sign up today
for a free trial so please do sign up
and let us know how it works out you can
go to cloud.google.com slash identity
and check the product out for yourself
for a 14-day trial
and give us your feedback thank you
[Music]